it seems like they're showing most of the footage
from i think is the battle of the stepstones which
was against the triarchy this big force from essos
one of the big trailer scenes that you see later
where damon targaryen is wearing a crown in his
head is basically him crowning himself king of the
stepstones after that battle like he comes back
thinking himself a king trying to present himself
like a conqueror but obviously graeme mctavish is
harold westerling here who's lord commander of the
kingsguard during this period wants nothing to do
with it because he literally pulls his sword on
him as he approaches his brother viserys the first
on the throne the opening scene of this extended
trailer is a stark contrast to that because it
takes place in the past because the young version
of vernier coming to see a younger version of
damon who's sitting on the iron throne we saw a
version of this scene earlier but you get a little
extra context here because harold westerling
earlier in the timeline opens the door for her
and it seems like it's supposed to be some kind
of secret meeting where he gives her that pendant
you see her wearing around her neck later in the
timeline when she's much older clearly if he
doesn't have a problem with damon targaryen
sitting on the iron throne earlier in the timeline
something has changed that makes him hate him a
little bit more later in the timeline this is just
meant to show some of the power dynamics between
the characters like obviously he sees himself
as his brother's successor to the iron throne
and she hasn't really thought too much about it
yet but then eventually she's named the successor
so he's trying to find another path to the iron
throne and eventually they do get remarried later
in the timeline when they're much older that's
what this scene is here where you see their
hands bleeding and claps together you also see
her taking her dress off here with them getting
ready to get it on when king viserys is talking
to the younger version of his daughter renee about
this dream that he had about all the dragons
roaring obviously it's meant to be a metaphor
about the coming targaryen civil war with all the
different targaryens yelling at each other all of
their different dragons that they ride yelling at
each other there'll be 17 dragons during the show
there's some extra scenes that clearly show that
it's her riding through the woods and riding with
her is a younger version of kristin cole you see
the firelight scenes of her talking to kristen
cole it's from that same part of the episode she's
talking to him wondering if the people of westeros
the other lords will ever accept her as their
leader obviously foreshadowing the coming dance
of the dragons but also what's going on here is
that as a young girl she actually had a big crush
on him but he didn't reciprocate her feelings and
leaves the thing's getting kind of messy like it's
kind of a jamie brienne situation the other really
notable thing about the dragons that i didn't talk
about in the previous trailer is there was some
footage of a mystery dragon's foot that was way
bigger than the other dragons that was probably
vhagar he's meant to be like the biggest dragon
that's alive during this period of the timeline
after the death of valerian the black dread what's
happening here later in the timeline is you have
a young version of eamonn one eye targaryen he's
the person that has the eye patch later in the
timeline he's trying to restore his honor by
becoming vhagar's next writer because he is the
biggest dragon so when he's successful everyone
thinks it's a really big deal the very simple
reason why he's bigger than a lot of the other
dragons on the show is just because he's older and
dragons just continue to grow and grow and grow
that was why bullying the black dread got so
big by his school's so big because he's about
200 years old when he died so the whole idea is
that some of the dragons that you meet on the
show were actually hatched by people way earlier
in the timeline really good example is the vhagar
dragon his first writer who hatched him was aegon
the conqueror's sister visenya then he was written
by balon targaryen who was the father of viserys
the first the current king in damon targaryen
his brother but the really interesting thing is
that after his father balon dies and viserys the
first is voted by the realm to become the next
king he does not take vegar he doesn't become
a dragon rider either like he doesn't write
any dragons during this period of the timeline
this is also the inside of the dragon pit that was
created after vegar was born so like one of the
ideas is the minute that they create the dragon
pit and start raising dragons and they're all
enclosed they start to grow smaller and smaller
and smaller and it starts to weaken targaryen
power and it's sort of like this ill omen for
their family and i know there's a big question
about who that dragon is at the end of the
trailers it's the same dragon in both of the
versions of the trailer it could be a version of
rhaenyra's dragon syrax or it could be a version
of vhagar it's just kind of hard to tell because
you don't see the entire dragon's head here
sometime soon i'll do a bonus video about all 17
dragons on the show who they are who their writers
are and who hatch them there's another brand new
scene of younger rhaenyra approaching her father
while he's praying to the skull of blaring the
black dread and he talked to her about how the
iron phone is the dangerous place on earth he's
not wrong about that not only does everybody want
the iron throne so everybody kind of wants your
blood but also the iron throne itself is made from
thousands of swords and will literally cut you if
you don't sit on it the right way that's why when
he's telling the story and he puts his hand on
the iron throne you see it bleeding although in
the grand scheme of things when people think about
viserys the first targaryen people usually think
about him as being kind of a weak king because
of the way he waited so long to name a successor
to the iron throne in the way that he did it
there are a couple scenes of younger allison
and younger rhaenyra praying together to the
maiden that's who this figure is zoom in enhance
you see in this scene she's wearing the necklace
that damon gave to her earlier like i said that
she's wearing it later in the timeline when she's
much older like it stays with her this whole time
this is also just meant to tease that they were
friends when she was at court they were younger
before she got remarried to her father then a
lot of people think that this person that wears
the mask with the burnt face is actually a version
of crab feeder his real name is kragus drachar he
appeared in the earlier trailers the reason why
people called him crab feeder is because one of
his go-to moves during big battles was to chain
prisoners up in low tide so that the water would
eventually come in and slowly drown them like
that's a pretty brutal way to take someone out
so that when the tide came in and drowned them
they would become crab food he was the crab
feeder very literally the reason why he'd be
wearing the mask while his face is disfigured
is probably because it got burnt by dragonfire
earlier in the timeline there's a new scene of
what seems like damon targaryen's hand putting the
cat's paws valerian dagger in fire to heat it up
what they explained is they actually upgraded the
prop so the person who wrote the original article
on it got a little bit confused it is meant to be
the same cat's paws dagger that littlefinger used
to start the war of the five kings and that arya
later used to kill the night king but what they've
done for the house of the dragon show is make it
a little bit more accurate to real-life daggers of
that period so the hilt is just like a little bit
shorter and it's a little bit more detailed like
it holds up in 4k just a little bit better later
in the trailer you see an older version of alison
try to pull it on older rhaenyra but you actually
also get some context for how she gets the
valerian dagger she literally steals it off of her
husband the king viserys targaryen like she grabs
it off of his belt then pushes him to the ground
and then jumps at raniera with the dagger we all
kind of wondered where she got it from this just
confirms the dagger belonged to viserys before we
saw it on the main show it doesn't confirm who
first owned the dagger it just confirms that